all right minnie yes
mimi uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh boone county west
virginia
and tell me about your childhood you had
mom and dad as a kid
uh yeah we uh i was born in the
ambulance
manchester and uh your brother
yeah he's in tennessee and uh they took
his hospital we stayed one night like
guys took us home and then back we lived
in a little
shack it's made like a chicken house and
we took uh baseboard boxes
boxes you carry stuff in kept the
corners out
and tagged them up on the wall to keep
the air out
and after we got all that out we'd take
newspapers
and mommy take flour and hot water
and make the paste with it that's the
old recipe you can try it
and we wallpaper the newspapers and
covered up over all the
the boxes that he put up to keep the
house warm and about 10 of us in there
sleeping
and it was rough really rough i mean i
came up like the roots
my daddy got bad super cancer and uh his
bowels was moving he couldn't do nothing
that way it me
i was my oldest sister than me to do all
the chores
like a whale went dry we had to figure
out how to dig it and
get the bronx and you know build back up
for us to have water
and uh we had to raise a garden
everything corn beans taters onions
coupons lettuce made your name
everything you name it we raised
everyone to eat
we cook beans we killed chickens
we had a big old pot of water outside
daddy came out there and wanted to get
the bullet it's like
all right you know what chicken for
supper get out of it
we didn't know what he meant to get
after he went there and kicking
we went over and got five and white
chickens
pull us and have a big table water down
a
hatch and he said now you can either
ring their neck
and kill them or you can chop their head
off we said no dad we don't want to
he said well you want to get live
chicken in hey you better get the cat
so we did we had chopped his head up i
brought his snake and
she chopped it off then we stuck it down
that big pot of hot water like that
and pulled it out and pulled the
theaters off of it and plucked it out
that hot water so we got it all out
and then we got it chased down
and you know got all that [ __ ] out and
had two thighs two eggs
and two wings and two chicken breasts
that's how many pizzas you get with
chicken
and how we bath was uh mommy and daddy
these two big long
tubs horse tubs and we pack water from
the creek and heat them on
two rocks to the side and get the heat
up and back for that for school
and then after we get down we'll just
take a washboard and scrub our
clothes out on it and make them out of
our hands and hang them up on a
nail in the house that way that'd be dry
next morning we're at school
but we really really had it right i mean
it was horrible
but i made it you know i mean
he just couldn't do the work we had they
had a meal ain't no transportation back
in you didn't have no transportation
about crank cars and she's rich
we had this mural and we lived at the
heart of where i was going to take you
where shell it is
uh we had to go to baton town once the
week that
once the night became about commodities
well we had to go down again so he made
that sweat i told you
and we took a horse mural down the main
town
and brought it back with the food on the
back of it i mean
it's really light if we wanted to eat we
had to raise your food
and go get the wood that was for furry
and you know work
we survived uh we beaten the cornbread
many times for breakfast
supper and dinner this is already
because you ain't got the money yeah
right you don't get it but this part of
appalachia is one of the poorest parts
of the country and then you are also in
a very poor family in this room
that's why because we was poor and
didn't have a fancy house and fancy cars
so
people made fun of us that's how we
consider them the whites
and they just kept doing it so we got
man [ __ ] we're nuts
we just showed them we're just good as
you are and then i thought we're not
rich
you're not gonna set your down ass and
talk about us we eat we get mine
and we don't ask you all for nothing
your whole family is pretty notorious in
this part of the country right yeah
them you're very well known well i got
um cemetery i was gonna show you
and what's left is this man jessica
and uh connie and sue bob and sue bob's
in jail she
freaked out on drugs don't know what
you're doing
actually sometimes she acts normal and
buddy she
gets crazy on that [ __ ] and she starts
doing everything so i killed a dog and
chopped it up
and put it in a bag and take it up and
burn it and he'll come to law 15 times i
suggest him
i've had enough fish [ __ ] now ain't no
dog here
her mind's gone and y'all to know this
[ __ ] i love her but what can i do with
her she won't listen to me i'll give her
cooked meals and feeding packets drugs
are drugs are pretty bad in this region
drugs are pretty bad in this region yeah
and uh
i don't do them when i drink i didn't
told that [ __ ] i just smoked pot
every now and then i didn't take no
pills i got them but for dogs but i
got rid of them how many kids do you
have i got three kids
one's dead and two is a wife and two two
girls are with me than
me one's 15 i think angel 48
and uh kimberly i raised her she was
born in 1903
and i was at the bar karyaking and my
friend she would get up here she's in
labor
you've been married before me yeah three
times
three times yeah and i went up and made
a grunt real fast and had that baby and
come out my cousin took the towel he
didn't cry
she just went like that and he didn't
hand it to that woman and the ambulance
well i thought her in the house i said
getting a baby debbie i want to see it
for she goes
i said lord it's your angel i'm going to
breathe my mouth please bring her right
i put my mouth over her nose your mouth
and breathe as hard as it could really
slow
and she came out of it and looked me in
the face and eyes at me
and i said boy you let me keep her she's
18.
and i'll uh y'all you go and take me on
out here you know
i gotta go with these kids ain't got
more one and mommy don't want them
have you ever considered leaving west
virginia have you ever considered
leaving west virginia sometimes i think
about where you and then when i think
about
i want to go to tennessee i know there's
money that'll be made i can make it
every night
i can have anything i want i've done
been down there
about it down through opry have you
traveled around the country yeah
if i can yeah they come and get me where
have you been
i've been to north oh god i've been in
north carolina south carolina virginia
georgia florida california
new york you've been around uh yeah i've
been everywhere
alabama uh [ __ ] i mean whoever was
and they've done shows and now all i had
to do was just go on stage and
and sing loretta lynn and to help dress
code same family condition
it started but he didn't know the words
so i had to fill in for him
how would you describe your brother
jessica he's a famous uh
he's like a little cult figure dancer
right yeah when he sets his mind or
something
he's he he means he's a musician too
right yeah
do you if he tells you something you
better believe it because he won't lie
to you that's one thing he won't do
and i can't go see man got no car if i
had a car i'd go sing
yeah he's in tennessee now i probably
have to be harassed to get in there
because man i got into it i went down
three times in that little red car i
bought
and every time i went she wouldn't cook
and who the hell cook
mashed potatoes green beans corn and mac
and cheese
and set it on the stove and then go
outside and turn the meat over ain't
even done
just put on tell me about living here in
in this part of the country i mean the
the hillbilly
culture is is strong here i mean every
like pretty much everybody here is
yeah everybody everybody here is doing
about the same thing
i didn't think i'd live to see madison
or boone county
the [ __ ] i see him out of people you
know backpackers and
sleeping on a creek bank i'll take and
show you he's got a tree built up in his
creek down there uh my house down the
hill there
over there i take your show you've got a
house me at the middle of the creek
and every time the water comes it washes
it out and he goes right back builds it
back again
here here in appalachia a lot of people
live in the abandoned houses
yeah they do they work in all kinds of
houses and they i'm not just that they
steal stuff
they go to the goodwill and get stuck in
and take and sell it brand new stuff
i've seen it they go crop pops and
everything there are people
have a lot of people that you knew from
earlier in your life left the region
have a lot of your the people that have
lived that you grew up with have
they left west virginia yeah they it's
like um
it's so poor here anywhere i go i don't
feel comfortable because it's like a
ghost town and when i go to bennytown i
have to go purple sun or twilight
and you know just like going into ghost
town everybody's inside you don't see
nobody walking no cats no dogs
and i have first little dad came to each
other
and it's like a little community anybody
that takes care of each other
and i don't i find a place if i grow up
this is my hometown
i was born raised up there over the best
years of your life
what were the best years of your life oh
well when i started filming really
because when i was growing up i had to
hustle and wrestle and
go sit and dance and then my mercy would
dance and
me and would give us some money but we
never drank we never take the opening we
just went down
played money and danced got mad and
danced to the jukebox
and it was good times then after god i
married this boy to get away from home i
never respect whipping
he tried to get me [ __ ] i got a big
knife i said yeah i feel like come here
ain't getting [ __ ] for me [ __ ] i
remember you get out here waiting
and i left never went back more and then
uh
i met eddie connie chapman sale at a gas
station
and he fell in love with me and i sort
of like tam to
make miss suddenly jealous of the
mouse's daddy
and we got together and got married and
stayed together about seven months then
he started cheating on me i just slowed
my [ __ ] up and left
told him bye-bye and then i married jake
angel's daddy i was murdered in seven
years
and well it was pretty good a little bit
my marriage with him he's pretty good
decent help me [ __ ]
and then he got the cirrhosis to the
liver and diabetic
and he uh he died with us
to live and we got the bar apart and
they caught and told us
we got the hell out i went up and got
him and then took him he got turned blue
from here
all the way around so you've been you've
been in love before
you've been in love before yeah three
times
one time i met eddie connie the second
time uh it took me years and years to
get over him
he died and he got his diabetes and took
his leg off
and he died he did old chat with him but
i voted him for years and years and
years but
i got open it wasn't easy about cracking
the idea
what's been the hardest time of your
life when i was growing up had digging
wells and
go get cold out of mountain snow on and
stuff
and build the bridge across the creek so
we get over to the bus stop
we had to go to school barefoot snow's
on and we'll show you where did you go
in school
i went to 8th grade and quit
[Music]
[Applause]
count it off
southwestern regional jail to accept
this call
press zero to refuse this call
this call is from a correction facility
and is subject to monitoring and
recording
thank you for using global tell link
are you doing i'm starting to soldier
damn i'm down here filming
i'm making my doing another movie i'm
down here feeling
it's all at the house i talked to
everybody in the pod they said
if he comes in here he's good you know
yeah
i mean uh i guess jessica was trying to
talk to me uh dakota just a few minutes
ago and
i guess that you know i mean they didn't
comprehend right you know i mean
they shot a letter down here saying this
business you know i mean but
he what happened was he went in and got
a pickle suit and went down there and
told on some stuff
and you know what i mean it was petty
you know what i'm saying but you know i
mean i talked to the people and they're
like well
you know i mean i pulled your strings
yeah well i appreciate it
you're welcome amy you know i do
anything for you how's jessica doing
she's doing all right
yeah she got the house waiting on me
i'm down here i'm done i'm down here at
the
park avenue filming if there's guys in
california and they move me
right how long do you think you'll be
i'll call i'll call back and talk to her
well probably about an hour or two you
can't tell by me
i might give me some beer and get on a
good
i'll see you later honey all right take
it easy [ __ ]
sorry it's okay so uh
do you uh do you go through uh emotions
like depression
anger stuff like that yeah i do that on
time constant
it don't look real good to tell about it
what's wrong with me because they're too
busy
wanting to cramp and hit the damn road
and get those and none of those don't
happen for that
i got everything wrong with me i got all
kinds of different operators in me
and it's drawing his finger right here
it won't go down
but sometimes it will go up one down and
then my face gone
the doctor said the nerves were damaged
and i got sisters in him he can't cut
him out except he did that my people
decay
so he wrote me a diabetic prescription
and told me get
the doctor write me new minds and they
won't write me any rhymes because i
smoke pot
so i'll get them off the street and they
just keep them and going like that
and then my back gets messed up the
total it's wiped out too
we've done three miles on it's total
everything i'm just told i'm trying to
tell them i'm ready for the junkyard
what what do you worry about what are
you afraid of uh
i'm not afraid you know the only thing
i'm worried about is trying to get my
babies back out here for three years
and god knows that i take care of that
babies better than anybody
i went down to the conference set and
sold pictures and autographs
until i got 50 bucks and gave it to her
[ __ ] to take them baby so they could
buy them rights
and then give them another bit they'd
buy them something to eat with
and if i hadn't done that they wouldn't
do it if the birthday comes around
i make the party better stuff have a
party for they don't about it
you have a lot of friends that are
involved in drugs and no i mean i do but
i don't
fool with them on that you know i can't
control everybody
i um i said this here everybody
is going to get on that mess i'm talking
about the hospitals
restaurants banks stores uh
any big publicly sooner or later
everybody's gonna be on it
and next thing you know we're gonna be
out here fighting for our life
to keep her home and keep food stuff
here it's the kind of around demand
people can't see what's the most popular
drug man crystal meth i guess
i don't do it i tried and i didn't like
it i don't like speed
i don't i do dope won't do another smoke
pot and take neurons
and i have to take them i won't be able
to walk and clean my house and stuff
what are you proudest of in your life
what are you proudest of
in your life the proudest part of my
life
when we came famous on the movie made it
in 1991
the dancing outlaw and from that day on
i
woke up and i've been on it ever since
you're like a
like a little celebrity from that yeah
yeah and your brother too
what's your biggest regret what's your
biggest regret
regret dying
i don't want to die and leaving
babysitting 18
like i've done the hell your grandkids
your grandkids you're talking about
yeah the two do they come in little
girls they're two and three-year-olds
and they let my friend have him and she
won't let me see him [ __ ]
and i had him for three years just take
him out of my heart like i snapped him
and then the one was 18 i raised she
found a boyfriend
i was hooked up with him waiting for the
18th to around and come around she all
there something moved up with me
so i got this man mouse and angel are
you religious
no i'm going to start probably going how
can you
when they run in and out some dope all
night long like deers
i'd still wait and guard make sure they
don't pack their food out enough to
backpackers
you call the the i go i go through the
drug addicts
backpackers the drug addicts are called
backpackers yeah they
they steal [ __ ] but we come up one day i
never
a friend of mine he wiped out and had
things like that sticking [ __ ] out of
garbage
oh um pop lids uh
those stick broke like it's crazy what's
wrong with packing your [ __ ] oh it's uh
it's with my head you're crazy that's
out here
i'll pay my go his wife is mine like
[ __ ]
he said stay up all night and play out
and plunder i don't like this [ __ ]
i'm talking keep me awake that's crazy
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
well when the we moved out of bennytown
this guy live inside of us and
he get to wind and watch us lay out in
the sun
and daddy caught him one day and told
him about it
and he said something that he said but
[ __ ] you then i'll move
we packed up and he showed him the land
we moved moved from there
and uh went down ducks branch and lived
there and that's where i left that
i went married this boy worked at this
store and he's in love with me but i
wasn't enough of him
how cause i had to do all the chores you
know mommy go to madison get groceries
we had at the house clean when she get
back i'm going by sweeping mopping
washington
driving that thing i mean i had a strict
father
my mom didn't do too much my dad was
strict
maybe what mean to us is just a strict
father
but we made it you know it was a rough
road to go down
i don't know if i could go down right
now with my help like yes
let's see they got everything shut off
now so who we live they got the roads
cut off but
lines and stuff up in there and it's
like a ghost town up there
what do you think the future is for this
region you know the coal mines seem to
be
drying up and uh drugs seem to be
stronger than ever
well if they would get rid of the
the drugs and this they piled out
the world will turn different it makes
people eat it makes them sleep it calms
them down
but map gets them into stealing [ __ ]
killing
odin and don't know what they're doing
geeking getting [ __ ] pointed out
open level cabinet door in the kitchen
let's see them open and why not now
they're looking for
so the world ought to stop the drugs
whoever made it and this let the
part go and it would be the wonderful
that's what we need to possibly do mommy
said
maybe i'm saying right now drugs and
then i'm going to figure this is going
through the world
and she was right everything she told me
to happen
about the end of time camera and always
stuff i know a lot
all right well thank you so much for
sharing your story you're much welcome
anytime
thank you john come down he climbed me
one hang out with me
never nobody really don't come up with
us to come up with a mouse and
then they go do their thing i sit and
watch two events like they're joining us